desde criança queria ser bailarina
não sei explicar porquê mas sempre que
podia dançava
mas comecei a sentir muito funk na sala
porque é muito mais alta do que os meus
colegas da escola ou do que as minhas
colegas do balé
nunca tive uma professora de dança
dizendo que eu era demasiado alta
não lembro ter sofrido bullying na
escola mas sentia que atraiu o olhar dos
outros e esse olhar incomodava
sentia me olhavam para o meu corpo e não
viam como pessoa na minha vida como
bailarina 101 sempre como um patinho
feio porque o meu corpo não corresponde
às minhas expectativas ou as dos outros
eu dançava vai mas no valê tinha
dificuldade em fazer as pontas ou em
levantar as pernas e não pensava ser
porque magoava outro fumava
apenas senti as limitações e culpado é
sempre o corpo na dança contemporânea é
não me identifiquei com alguns dos
conceitos negou de construção do corpo
eo movimento nos dança espanhola sobre
games dançar com o exagero do sentimento
por querer essa expectativa do público
que confunde este exagero com saleiro
mim é minha tentativa de corresponder às
expectativas que criou uma ruptura na
minha relação comigo própria ao tentar
integrar me obriguei o meu corpo será o
que não era entortava as costas para mim
fazer mais baixa
estava sempre a engordar e emagrecer e
andava sempre cansada e com insônia mas
gostava muito de dançar e especialmente
as danças espanholas durante muitos anos
de aulas fiz muitos espetáculos porque o
meu corpo se ele estava muito bem este
tipo de linguagem mas continuava a não
ser a sua linguagem natural é a
linguagem do meu corpo que eu nunca lhe
permite que expressasse porque achava
que não era nada especial
quando comecei a fazer ioga com a minha
mestra é professora diz o art
comecei a recuperar ea descobrir um
corpo que eu não sabia que tinha e quase
sem dar conta conseguiu tomar
consciência de verdade muito simples o
meu corpo é diferente e único e não tem
de estar a comparar com os outros
as minhas limitações são estas que eu
posso lhe mar e ver como oportunidades
de mudança algo que eu via como uma
limitação à final até pode ser uma
qualidade praticar yoga com esta
professora ajudou a descobrir o meu
corpo e o movimento envolveu uma dança
estou a aprender a confiar no meu corpo
e mais importante ainda aprender a
servir na sua confiança mesmo que isso
implique esforço
tudo isso foi tão importante para mim
que se vê que o próximo espetáculo
tributo tratar de alguma forma esta
minha relação com o yoga com este
espetáculo pretende fazer uma chamada de
atenção procura
mas não meu porque o meu sou e
referência para mim própria
é o corpo humano e sua sofisticada
tecnologia também foi a minha professora
é que me desafiou voltar à faculdade em
filho meu mestrado em dança e entre o
produto eo momento precisamente no ano
em que foi aprovada a criação dos
instrumentos práticos em dança em
portugal que permitem apresentar um
espetáculo tudo se conjugou e poderá sim
conciliar esta minha ideia de fazer um
novo espetáculo com o doutoramento e
como resultado de todo esse trabalho
isto descobrir a minha dança e chame
mudança temporária porque vai fora do
tempo e faz o elogio da beleza e da
simplicidade do gesto é minha meditação
em movimento
é algo que tem a ver com saúde e
corrupção é uma das sondas estrutura é
base da criatividade e um do respeito e
vaso de tudo todos no meu percurso na
dança só foi possível porque a senhora
dança é generosa e inclusiva como dizia
a minha professora de yoga
eu como professora de dança preocupa
esta ideia de que ainda existe de
criança é igual a valer ouro que o
valley e vaso de todas as danças
normalmente quando uma criança diz que
quer ser bailarina é logo encaminhada
para as aulas de balé também aconteceu
mesmo ea criança começar a encaixar
senna que o modelo é e começar a criar
um é um sonho de ser bailarina clássica
e infelizmente a maior parte das vezes
esse sonho desfeito porque o corpo não
consegue corresponder a todas as
exigências e pessoa acaba por deixar de
dançar o valer é muito bonito mas não é
para todos os corpos
é dança assim essa pode ser para todos
infelizmente foi teimosa e continua
sempre na dança
sempre acreditei que na dança há lugar
para todos porque lances são muitas
danças
dança pode ser uma lei mas também pop o
kuduro ou as danças tradicionais dos
vários países já a argentina chinesas
as portuguesas e espanholas africanas
brasileiras etc
o importante é termos professores que
nos orientem pra dança que circula mais
as nossas características e as nossas
capacidades físicas e expressivas ou
podemos simplesmente encontrar a nossa
própria dança circo de obra si mesmo e
descobrir o seu corpo real e saudável é
transcender as limitações e dar sua
direita ser diferente e único
amplamente seu direito de existir e ser
autônomo e podemos todos ser curiosos
nós mesmos não só na dança
mas na vida deixe este desafio
experimentem obrigada pati quinto rodas
posso dizer
o teu corpo não pretende se o ar que
respira
a terra pizzas a água que tocas a chama
que senti nada de pertença porque passa
pela morada nem usam do tempo é bem
estar de passagem na tua viagem pelo
universo e tudo o que vivemos é sempre
tensa vida
mestre falando do corpo
o corpo
esse vitorioso guerreiro de tanta giva
salvador as batalhas escutam e
tranqüilizam respeita à morada que vidas
mantenha sua casa arrumada a qualquer
momento receber as visitas
que responsabilidade ser pena
saem pena nenhuma de eu ser a
simplicidade ser pina
ser humilde e saber que eu veja de uma
pena
tem o peso que tem que ter
que harmonia e equilíbrio que conquista
no olhar
que gesto delicado no corpo nuclear é
dança é movimento é criação é um momento
único
saí repetição mestra falando da
respiração respira
e sinto o cântico da vida a vida que
respira em ti sem usar partilha
a creche e vivo com o que inspira e
nunca expira em
estreita a atuação na minha
faz nenhum instrumento da tua não
o guia o meu caminho no teu 2030 o
coração seja divina memória origem de
todo o meu ser campeã em todas as
células
todos tiraram pertencer e nunca suspiro
e canto só um sopro me animar a cantar a
tua glória num corpo de louvar a
porque olha
como quem me vê o procura porque escutas
como carne ovo ou que é executado se no
alto não me encontra se em baixo não
vejo olha me escuta dentro dele pois só
através do interior do instrumento que
toco e faz lembrar a ética vejam em mim
ética que faz sentido de escutar sem
confundir dentro como dentro sinta
fronteira da tabela sendo o exterior do
teu corpo toma consciência de maya e
sendo ela de vinho e entregue até a
nossa dança